お肉を禁止して週間以上経ってるんですけども
なんか余裕です弾みそうです何か食べて魚を食べるから被害と全然大丈夫でそんな食べ
たいとも思わないし
焼肉には
死ぬほど行きたいですはいだけで今日はですねこちら皆さん知ってますでしょうか
ルービックキュールービックキューブなんですけども僕本当に何も分からないんですよ
なんかいままでルービックキューブできたらかっこいいなーとか思ってなんですけども
一度溶けるケースな一面がないなら行けますちょっとおっ
でもひっついたんだけど今からどれか揃えますじゃあ黄色遊べますね良いだ
[音楽]
はいはいはいはいはいあっはっは
くるりんときてこうしてこうだ
2分ぐらいかかりますあとはごちゃごちゃですが1便じゃないのは全然1レースで僕の
頭脳だったらね
ただもう2面とかになると本当に無理なんでちょっと赤揃えてみましょうか
集団にが4月様しなくなるんだよ
[音楽]
マンネリだめだよくないよくないだってあかうけアソートさ黄色がダメになるんですよ
無理こういうめっちゃ速いと言うじゃないですかこういう
[音楽]
あれでなりたいあれやりたいんですけどもその時期になれる気がしない+1日かけて
やろうと思ったんですよ
なんか適当にやってたらできるかなと思ったんですけどモダンして無理でしたたぶん僕
のあの人だと思ってあげる今日の企画はもうなんとせてもレーベル旧ボトル揃えようと
いう企画ですごめんなさい本当に僕が揃えたいだけです本当に知識のない人で暴力とか
なんかねってをすることがあるんでそれを見
てバックがルーディック系を全面揃えるのにどれだけの時間がかかるのが調べて行き
たいと思いますまずで知識ないですよほんとになんで僕が今たがネットの情報とが
いろんなをすべて駆使してこれを受け目揃えてたらタイムだったらたぶん皆さんも
できると思うので是非試してみてはいかがでしょ
では図っていきます用意
さあと nande
ルービックキューブを路へ方
sl ルービックキューブを6メートルを得られる人は全世界で6%しか言いたいね
そんな言ってる場合じゃないってどうすればいいんだろうずる技ウラワザ最短手順そう
するとそれぞれ何
命張って守って本当に難しい諸待ってパターンがあるの独立や多関節型セットを買った
客再生方
f
いろんなパターンがあるから必ずこれをやればできるっていうのがないらしいですね
助けてやっぱり何もから難しいせるずに reir
だし fr fr 2 r 2 f あるですえっ
持って本当に減る分だけどやあ結構結構やばい結構やっぱり結構やっぱ結構山へ
結構やばいマって結構やばいこれよりもうかにょ一番詰めることからって事一面から
解いてるんだっても1面
揃え方はわかるんですよ tomotomo それしかできないくらいなんすよ
[音楽]
て
っていうキターはいいやそれはわかったんですよだから5名はできるんですよ
雑魚なんですよここに徹しろソロ8日
言わせてみまして入れてゆくはい
まあ一面は全然できるんですよね何か良い消そうと気がします道を見てきました
3日
nao
うん
[音楽]
おっ
でも生きすればいけそこんなんかなんかなんか
おっお
こんな鉄本渓スピードなんだよな
[音楽]
まって本当に難しいんですけど
山
日ごと一番
難しい難しいなこれちょっとなめてましたーーー
ん
やばいあったはちょっとやり直しますダメの難しすぎるって
電磁気レター
[音楽]
んあっ終わった終わったそれを破ったん
なるほど分かってきたと分かってきたぞそういう仕組みか
おおっ
いけるいける空の2打目は全部揃えました
いけるぞ俺これを予告に結構
[音楽]
あっはイヤーね水なここまできて最後難しいやつよこれ
やはり雑種お菓子おかしくなっちゃって私困った詳しく立つとおかしくなっておかしく
なっておかしくなっちゃった
ペットで待ってを付けなっちゃったいっ
[音楽]
あっ発掘被ってると思ってるちょっと待ってぺんっ
すごいすごいもうもうもう目前も僕税
[音楽]
ねおかしくなっちょっとおかしくなっちゃったよ
星爸爸慌てるのはから難しいんですよ
オーラスている今からがきついということを
まあ変なことすんだよね戻れなくなるぞこれまで大丈夫か
戻れなくなるぞやめろ変な音せーの俺や化け猫とするんじゃないよ
では行ったがファー
あああああって本当にこれやばない
ああ
します
まあてこっからなんで国家が強引でこっから
[音楽]
山もうもうできそうなんですけど最後の詰めがまずで難しい気がする
私塩コショウ星なんて言ってるんだよなもう待って行った川行ったかも行った彼も
やはり
でもやったった今では去って行くない曲ない戻したに戻したいあの頃に戻りたい
待ってダメダメだ山田あまりめめ m 夢これジョブでこれぞに無理だわかんだろうか
どうかない
ただ者で誰誰誰誰だろ
あっホワイエにもいければ付ける6月6月たかこれ
いきます
うん
高
おおおおおおおお
[音楽]
パパ
ああああああああ
できたぁー
帰って帰ってる自分
んえっっ
[音楽]
me
me あっ